- I love Lisa.
(audience applauds)
- [Rose] That's it. (claps)
- Lisa Rinna, your wife.
So she recently ended her
run with Real Housewives.
- She did.
- Were you excited about that?
- I am thrilled about that.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I get my wife back, you know?
(Kelly laughs)
Okay?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So for fans of that show, sorry,
she's not gonna be there,
but I get her back.
(audience laughs)
- That's awesome.
What's your favorite reality show?
You watch reality TV?
- You know what?
The Housewives.
- [Kelly] Really?
Of Beverly Hills.
- [Harry] No kidding, really?
- Yeah, that was the only one
I ever really got into it.
It was so entertaining!
Oh my goodness.
- Well, it's amazing the
people who watch this show.
- [Rose] I-
- And who don't admit
that they watch this show.
- Oh!
- [Kelly] Oh, really?
- I only,
I walk through the room
and it's on with my wife.
- Yeah.
- And I see it.
But no, they're all, they all-
- I don't believe in guilty pleasure.
I just believe in pleasure.
I don't know why people
(Harry laughs)
always say like
"guilty pleasure."
- I agree.
Yeah.
- Yeah, I'm like,
we just like it.
- You got that right!
- Yeah, what's
wrong with just liking it?
- Pleasure is pleasure.
Yeah.
- Exactly.
- And it's character study,
you know what I mean?
- It is!
- You can look at it like that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like this behavior
of these people.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's like, and I know a lot of it
is set up and, but.
How long has she done it for?
- She did it for eight years and
now she's off and time.
- [Rose] That's a long time.
And I have a degree in
psychology and I was-
- Oh, what do you think?
- I was able to
pull it out
and use it.
- [Kelly] Do you really?
(Rose laughs)
- I do, from Yale.
- What?!
- I do.
- 'Cause you also wanted
- [Rose] Let's break it down,
- to be an architect, I know.
- Harry, come on.
- Right?
Was architecture-
- Well, originally.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- When I left high school
that's what I wanted to do.
But I got kind of sidetracked
by a Hell's Angel
in some tree houses in
La Honda, California.
- Did Snoop give you a blunt too?
Like-
(audience laughs)
- It was more than a blunt.
(all laugh)
Anyway, I got,
I got sidetracked.
- Oh my god.
- And I missed my registration
to the architecture school.
I only had 45 minutes to register.
I was gonna have to wait a
whole quarter to re-register.
And the guy at the
architecture school said,
"You know the drama department
is right over there,
and if you run over there
now, fill out the forms,
you might be able to get
it in under the wire."
- That worked out.
Yeah, how about that?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I never looked back.
- I love the love of architecture.
I do too.
I think it's so interesting
how people's minds work.
Beautiful, like architecture.
- And I still am into it.
- I love architecture.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I built a house
and I also built a
couple of retail stores,
so I got a little bit
out of my blood.
- That's cool.
You get do all of it, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Well, how about the psychology degree?
Did that work out?
How are you using that? (laughs)
- Well, I used that to help
Lisa get through that show.
(all laugh)